I think it's about three percent of the
world population are living in countries
where fertility is not declining so the
idea that you know the population is
growing is very old news immigrants get
old immigrants stop having kids as well
um you know it's it's the same type of
thing you're just getting in
um essentially a new dependent class
because you know they're they're not
gonna they usually have you know maybe
more children than the than the typical
you know Westerner for maybe one or two
generations but it declines already
fairly steep once they get here you know
we're going to get off the pill are we
going to you know get off of the
Industrial Revolution yeah you know this
is the toothpaste meat tube type
situation I don't want people to end up
in that position where that realization
comes that late and there's maybe not a
huge amount you can do about it and I
think that's tragic actually
hello and welcome to trigonometry on
location I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is returning to the show
she's a writer and the host of the
subversive podcast Alex casuto welcome
back thank you so much for having me and
as we said we're on location London
which is why we are more fancily dressed
than normal and the set
the set is what the set is uh but anyway
welcome to London uh it's great to have
you back on I've been following your uh
your writing and the things you say on
social media with great interest you
just spoke at the netcon conference
where we we where we are as Mutual media
of course we are
um
what are you thinking about right now
what is what is what is sort of peaking
your curiosity what is interesting to
you at the moment
of I think the the main theme of the
conference seems to be the um the
fertility crisis you're doing your job
yeah I'm doing my my part I've been
actually praised for my pregnant lady
outfits when I came in here thank you
and I've worked a lot with them because
yeah you need pregnant lady outfits I've
learned
um so I think this has been kind of in
in The Ether in uh it's also been on my
mind I was thinking about actually
speaking on this topic but I'm kind of
glad I didn't because it seems to be
very well covered it definitely would
have brought something really redundant
to the to the theme
um and it seems to also be very spicy in
the UK context because I've been looking
at okay healthy how have people reacted
and you know even like the insinuation
that um you know uh mother and father
type of combo should be normative in
society seems to have sparked like uh
pretty much insanity and in the UK media
and
um yeah I mean the idea that okay you
know
the fertility crisis seems to be tied
into
um the idea that okay the only way to
solve this is some form of coercion and
this is what you know the fascists that
navcon want you to do and
um yeah it's magazine women have the
babies yeah exactly but but before we
get into that a lot of people who are
really not familiar with any of these
conversations will be thinking what
fertility crisis we've got a population
problem population is going to Boom
everyone's going to die of climate
change Etc so what is the fertility
crisis I don't think that's the case I
mean at least in terms of kind of the
the newer data that we have is that I
think it's about three percent of the
world population uh is the are living in
countries where fertility is not
declining so the idea that you know the
population is growing is very old news
the population is falling pretty much
everywhere and it's not falling in the
sense of like you can't feel it in the
water right now if you go out on the
street plenty of people there you know
you might see more elders really people
slowly but it's not something that's
like an urgent problem but the fact that
you know the population pyramids in
pretty much every region are are
reversing
um and you have many more older people
than younger people it's something that
can have extreme like like knock-on type
domino effect consequences that you know
people are just starting to model and
starting to realize I mean it's
predicted that a country like uh like
South Korea who's has you know abysmal
birth rates they've Fallen under one uh
one child per couple like the TFR is
like 0.9 something
um it they're essentially going to die
out so this is kind of we're watching
the last South Korean slowly kind of
March onto so there are Graves if this
trend continues and they're not going to
die out in like 500 years this is pretty
much an about 100 to 150 years you know
you'll see the last South Koreans say
goodbye to them and you know this is
only just like a startling example but
the same trend line applies to pretty
much everywhere in the west with very
few exceptions I mean
um like consistently over a replacement
fertility rates you have in places like
Israel and like the Amish community
in Mormon communities in the US but even
they are just just about at replacement
and probably going to fall under
replacement very soon so this is
a form of you know you know essentially
what people are trying to do now is to
um identify what exactly causes this and
you know overall there's there are many
factors that can go into it there's you
know environmental factors you know even
like kind of xenoestrogens in the water
things that might affect you know that
we've heard about declining testosterone
uh you know fertility issues for for
younger and younger women the fact that
most people who want to have children
after a certain age need IVF there's
there's all sorts of factors going into
it but
um I think the conclusion that a lot of
people at napcon arrived at and one that
I have as well is that the main factors
are essentially cultural like we've
really
you know once children became optional
we've really kind of lost the the will
to have them in the sense because they
are really a burden in a way and I think
people can you know they they can't
really model their lives with children
but they know how they feel right now
and they know that okay you know
sleepless nights cost of daycare you
know I'm renting I don't want to have
that hassle you know all these things
it's it's just not worth it to a lot of
people is it really cultural though
because
um look the housing crisis is a UK very
specific problem but that's part of it
but just more broadly uh urbanization
means you know Peter zahan who we've had
on the show and talked about this when
you live on a farm kids are free labor
when you live in the city they're like
an expensive pet of course yeah right so
it's fun mate yeah it depends you can
argue that you know urbanization is
something that's kind of tied into
culture as well I mean the incentives
for for urbanization are kind of memetic
as well it's not like it's not just
people chasing money but it's you know
it's a culture that forms after these
kind of after the Industrial Revolution
as well people kind of gather it in
urban centers to you know to work on the
factories and a certain kind of culture
emerged around that and then a fertility
rate dropped to the level of that
culture of people you know being
together in that environment so I think
what we what we've reached now is the
point where kind of a lot of these memes
converge and for the life that the
typical individual leads and and these
uh in these cities
and yeah it's just it doesn't make
logical sense to to have children and
yeah and as well governments aren't
really doing anything to incentivize
people either I mean the Hungarian
government does to be fair to them yeah
but certainly the British government you
you look it's a tough one yeah you look
at what they're doing you think well
they're just exacerbating the problem
aren't they yes in a way they are but if
you if you look at you know places that
had incentives for uh for you know
raising the the birth rate it is
marginally productive even the places
who've imposed like you know kind of
significant centers like hungry it's
it's it kind of works I think they've
bumped it up by 0.2 or 0.3 after you
know massive cultural programs and and
all of that
um but yeah the trend lines still you
know they're really fighting an uphill
battle it's it seems to be very hard to
lift I think the only country who's
actually gotten it back from below
replacement to above replacement is
Georgia because they've been
um I think the local patriarch people
are very religious in Georgia
baptizes every third or fourth child
that a family has so like big families
are incentivized to you know get to the
special ceremony to to yeah to meet the
patriarch and have their child baptized
by him so yeah I think you know a
strange exotic type of you know
incentive that I don't necessarily know
would work here I don't know if the
Archbishop of Canterbury would you know
pump people up to to have lots of kids
but um yeah I mean you know the housing
crisis I think is really an important
thing as well but if I if I think back
at you know all of the the squalor and
and struggle that my ancestors went
through and just the material conditions
that they had children and it you know I
don't think the fact that they rented
and didn't own was was a big problem for
them or you know the cost they had
different social Technologies around
them as well like they had family they
had support networks and all of that but
it was also culturally the thing that
you did
um and it was not really optional in the
sense that you would you know if you
didn't do this you were probably going
to be stigmatized or you would feel bad
about yourself if you you know you were
a spinster or you didn't you know
participate in
um in growing the clan and all the
Traditions that tied into that and when
you know you had the cultural uh the not
the cultural revolution the Industrial
Revolution and all the things that kind
of uh came with it you know the family
just didn't work the same way you know
people moved away for work they um they
preferred to live alone because you know
family is wonderful but it's also kind
of a hassle and if you can help it you'd
probably move away from in-laws and most
people did so it's also the abundance
that that the Industrial Revolution and
all the Technologies coming with it
created that allowed us to to atomize
ourselves because you know like in
economics it is a it is a revealed
preference people like to you know mind
their own business you know it's like we
were talking before this you know with
communities something beautiful but it's
for when other people do it it's much
nicer you know other people really need
Community I'm I'm kind of a loner myself
but we're also ignoring the elephant in
the room which is the pill
yeah yeah I think the the pill is a is a
major factor in there
um the thing is birth rates were falling
before the pill as well so it's kind of
a a trend that was already in motion and
the pill was definitely not uh
decelerant it really kind of
um
um yeah helped to stoke the fires of a
trend that was already in motion so it's
not the pill or the pill may have
contributed let's say yeah so when we
talk about the cultural developments
that are a product of urbanization
whatever so what's going on Alex because
there's part of me that thinks that uh
when we delve into this issue we're
going to find a lot of things we don't
like pretty quickly in terms of you know
the correlation between prosperity and
the number of children people have you
know do we need to be poorer so that we
start reproducing is it about women's
Liberation if we liberated women too far
like that would be a question some
people ask I'm not saying I'm asking it
but people will will start to ask all of
these questions you talk to I've been
talking to a lot of people at the
conference about it like Louise Perry
she's like it's all about Prosperity you
talk to Eric Kaufman he'll say well it's
about religion you know and he's not
religious but religious communities
reproduce and non-religious basically
don't like where do you see the The
crucial piece of this
yeah I think it's you know unfortunately
it's it's hard to um kind of delineate
which particular ingredient in this
because these are all kind of factors
that accentuate each other and uh it's
hard to say what you know what the first
Domino was when you know you're like 100
Dominoes down the line yeah
um so I think you know in a way the
education of women was was a big thing
you know it kind of um
freed women from marriages that were um
not necessarily of convenience but in
the sense that you know they really were
dependent in many ways for men for
protection and for financial support
which you know not saying anything about
the quality of those marriages a lot of
marriages you know are arranged or or
you know maybe coerced a little bit in
the beginning and people end up having a
really good marriage
um so not saying that that's a bad thing
but uh it uh you know the fact that
people did have a lot more options like
in the case of having children as well I
think led to uh decline in marriage
rates and then you know in the revealed
preference of not having to deal with
each other's uh and so the
inevitable question is if we are to
address this problem yeah what do we do
yeah you know it's like kind of a
Pandora's Box type situation uh putting
the the toothpaste pack in the tube
um it's it's a tough one I mean I feel
like
obviously what I'm part of and what I'm
trying to do is kind of more of a you
know incentivizing people culturally to
um you know adopt this meme of
pronatalism because I mean I I can be
only one a testimonial of one it's been
really a miraculous thing for my life
and I know for my husband as well I mean
yeah I don't want to speak from him but
yeah I can because you know he's very
happy being a dad
um and yeah you know the people that I
know around me are also you know
completely enamored by their children
um there's also you know the downside is
of of building this up too much because
obviously there are downsides you know I
think there's also kind of a very Trad
movement now that it's like oh you know
this is this is going to solve all your
psychosis all your problems are gonna
are gonna be solved by having children
uh it's all upside obviously it's not I
mean you know people have the Instinct
that this is going to derail their lives
and they're very very right it's going
to completely restructure the way you
relate to yourself to your partner to
your life to what your priorities are
but for most people this is a good thing
I really think so because
a lot of the problems that people have
psychologically with with kind of the
burden of modernity is this aimlessness
of okay what is it that I'm supposed to
be doing you know there's no guard rails
it's all about you self-creating you
know building this unique uh you know
snowflake type thing that that only you
represent you know Finding Your
authenticity going to whatever silent
Retreats and meditating on what it is to
be alive and stuff like that and I've
personally found by doing this stuff is
it feels like it's kind of an eternal
Circle you're kind of always back to
square one and it's like you know
whenever you think you've had this major
Epiphany that you've kind of fought
yourself out of your thinking process
you're back in in the
do you think part of the problem as well
is that we are accustomed to living a
life where our own pleasure is the main
thing
yeah I think that's that is part of the
problem
um it's it's a hard problem to solve
because that's kind of the most uh
immediate thing that you want to do
because you know in a way we're like at
base for all animals and you know you
want to scratch a niche and you know eat
the eat the candy and do all that stuff
plus there are so many ways to scratch
so many itches that you didn't even know
you had and probably didn't have until
you know yesterday when you saw hmm
people are having this itch online maybe
I should scratch it so um I think that's
uh you know something that people
underestimate like the memetic power of
a lot of the stuff that comes comes in
from the internet I mean you know the
kind of more benign ways that you know
some company convinces you to buy shoes
off of the internet the more kind of
vicious way is that you know your 14
year olds convinced to top of her
breasts because she saw I don't know 500
Tick Tock videos of people saying this
is really satisfying doing so
um yeah I mean it's it is a very strange
new world and it is you know kind of all
about this
because we don't have a structure to fit
into to say okay how what is what is
life you know life is you wake up you go
feed the animals you have this this
responsibility this fills up your entire
day
um and then you go to bed and you you
know you say your prayer and you you
know you report to to this Authority and
you're kind of inbuilt into the system
and everyone else believes the same
thing because obviously this is what you
believe
um I think you know since time
immemorial we had something like that
now we don't have anything like that and
people are told okay it's time for you
to to make up on the Fly whatever you
think that thing is you know and I don't
think most people probably very few
people are equipped to actually do that
you know to create their own
authenticity from scratch and then they
fall prey to a lot of this stuff that's
just like out there in The Ether and a
lot of the stuff is really predatory
like you know whatever slot machine
gambling now it's like you know slot
machines used to be really bad and like
even the 80s but nowadays they have
essentially the same logic and built a
Candy Crush and you have people just
like sitting in front of the slot
machines you know peeing on themselves
after three days and you know like dying
of dehydration because this stuff is
just so powerful
um and we're really not equipped to deal
with it and yeah like I said not just a
slot machines like everything is like
that now and you know the free market
idea is that you know there's a need
markets feel you need these people have
a need to you know die of dehydration in
front of a slot machine because they
keep doing it they keep pulling the
lever Free Will they've they're
consenting to do it so
um yeah I think a lot of our environment
is is set up like that and
you know maybe this Trad stuff and you
know kind of back to the land all this
stuff is kind of a bit of a backlash
against that you know I don't
necessarily think it's all you know
Super Wise and I think a lot of people
you know I hear stories of you know like
19 and 20 year olds now getting married
just in and being afraid of all this
stuff that we're talking about the
predation that they see around them and
then they get really kind of
disillusioned by the fact that you know
marrying some random 19 year old who
thinks that you know the West has fallen
off the internet is uh is not like an
idyllic way of living and it's not
really like you know in the pictures of
you walking through a wheat field with
your babies and stuff so
yeah we definitely had a sort of kind of
metaphysical Crossroads and and how we
relate to ourselves and the and in the
West in general and people feel like
they've lost a lot
um but we're still kind of fumbling in
the dark about what to do what to do
about it and one of the interesting
things that has risen with this whole uh
natalism conversation is a rise of
surrogacy now you look at it on the
surface you go okay this is you know
this is good you know people who can't
have kids can have kids what's what's
wrong with that and then you look into
it you go oh this is dark yeah yeah it's
a it's a strange thing because obviously
the kind of the more kind of napkin
presentation of the case for surrogacy
is is really nice you know you have you
know women who maybe don't are not of
you know great means you know but are
willing to do it for kind of generously
to to help someone who maybe is
infertile and they really want their own
child and this is the only way they can
have it it's really you know it kind of
feels on heartstrings especially if
you're someone who knows you know art
and fertile yourself or you know it's
it's it's it's tough out there like I
said you know a lot of people are having
trouble with this
um and it feels like oh you know you
scratch my back I scratch yours type of
situation
um but I think the the case for it
um or against it in a way is kind of a
case of like like virtual ethics like if
we allow this type of um activity to to
start and if we allow this little Edge
case where you know it's obviously
virtuous and nice
um the thing is not going to stay there
you know we have we have you know
slippery slopes are all around us and
we've been slipping on so many uh and at
this point where I think surrogacy
especially commercial surrogacy and
cross-border Commercial surrogacy
is already a little bit of a of a
strange
um beast because you know especially now
with the war in Ukraine you know this is
kind of a lot of the cup uncovered was
essentially that a lot of people who
were evacuating were these kind of like
big brother style houses of women who
you know were living kind of in a
cluster home I don't know pregnant with
some westerners baby and they were kind
of keep being kept in sort of um
I don't know observation so that the the
moms and dads or whoever was ordering
the baby from abroad was uh yeah it was
kept in check of how the ladies were
doing and stuff like that so I don't
know it was a
yeah I mean you could see this we're
still at the beginning of this and this
is already kind of you know it feels a
little bit predatory and it feels a bit
predatory to interrupt and just
completely like commercially sever the
bond between Mom and baby I mean I've
I've had a baby I'm gonna have one again
very soon and it's uh the idea that you
know in the hospital even though if I
signed the contract before obviously you
know I consented to this previously
without knowing how I'd feel when the
baby arrived
um I would just have to you know give
the baby you know just hand it over and
say sayonara I'm gonna go home now
um so yeah there's also a lot of you
know physical costs involved
um yeah it's it's you know recovering
from pregnancy is not always easy
there's risks of you know risk that is
really hard to calculate in advance as
well in terms of the impact on your
health you know some women you know end
up having like stress fractures uterine
ruptures all sorts of you know things
that just happen in the course of not
being pregnant
um might lead to infertility for
themselves afterwards so yeah I mean
obviously if someone's more of a
Libertarian event they say okay you know
if you put this in a disclaimer put it
in the contract obviously let them know
that this you know side effects might
include this this and this but I think
when it comes to something so profound
as the the bond between a child and and
mother
um you know I don't think your body
knows that oh this is someone else's egg
and this is some you know third-party
sperm and you know this is a strange
it's a different situation but yeah it
just feels like
you know one of those slopes that you
know it's you can tell when you reach
the precipice that it's like this this
is the direction it's going into and
we're just about there and we're taking
the first step down the slope and it's
you know the The Darkness at the bottom
is essentially you know people ordering
babies for anything well it comes back
to the point you were making about the
markets like what is the commodity
that's being traded in that exchange uh
and and it starts to get a little bit
creepy very quickly and then first
Francis says once you look into it then
it sort of starts to make sense a little
bit but I want to come back to what what
can be done about it because
um I was chatting to a bunch of uh young
women at the conference uh and I
actually did something I don't usually
do which I just stood back and listened
for a long time uh and there's a kind of
different set of perspectives on this
because there are some some people who
go well you know we got to put the
message out there and whatever and there
are other people who I think quite
rightly say well look like a guy on
stage telling me a bunch of statistics
about when I'm supposed to get pregnant
by isn't really gonna persuade me to do
it and I did you know since I've had my
son a year ago I've been putting out
like wholesome first traps on the
internet about like is this is how fun
it is this is how much I'm enjoying
here's a cute photo whatever even though
I'm gonna stop doing that
um what is the way uh to to just let
it's not about persuading people into
doing stuff it's just like letting them
know that that option that we talked
about
has all these benefits that you might
not see because you're living in you
know in a big city you may none of your
friends have kids you know the one of
them was saying I didn't hold my first
baby until I was 30 which to me I'm
probably to you being Eastern European
you're like what you know no that was
the case for me as well
I was like totally surrounded by babies
no that's pretty normal on Eastern
Europe yes I'm just a bit of a freak
so what do you think is some of the what
is the best way to communicate about
this issue yeah I think there's kind of
a a two-pronged thing I really I agree
that the you know the young ladies on
this really be convinced by you know a
graph here look at the graphics it's
real bad if you don't pop them out
tomorrow yeah
um yeah I don't think that's that's good
and I do think kind of your approach of
thirst strapping is probably more
um more suitable to to to how to do it
um I think people seeing High status
people people that they look up to
people that they want to emulate doing
these things and presenting it like I
said in a bit of a realistic manner
because you know you can also have the
the overshot where it's just all just
wheat fields and you know women
surrounded by by seven babies you know a
real thin with their you know Wonderful
blonde hair you know flowing in the wind
that happens but it's it's really the
case it's usually a bit more hectic if
you have seven babies you know it's
they're not all chill all the time and
all this type of stuff so yeah I mean
it's that's correct I'll stop posting
his photos and I'll just stop stop
posting isn't that easy like the kitchen
table after he's done throwing stuff
everywhere yeah just I think if put like
five adorable thirst traps of wonderful
things just throw a dirty nappy in there
occasionally still remind people that
there's a bit of a bit of a downside in
there as well
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch-up is on locals
are War shows still go out at 7 pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch some after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
and the reason I feel really strongly
about this is I don't know if I told
this in on on in public before but uh I
did this uh discussion unheard a few
months back and Freddie who Freddie says
who hosted he said to me
um he said there's something different
about you since you became a father
there's something different and I went
well yeah the future is not an
abstraction anymore it has a face and it
has a name
uh which I I hadn't thought about before
but that's what came to me in the moment
and then as we were standing outside I'd
broken all my post-father promises and
bummed a cigarette off Freddy and I was
him and I was standing there smoking and
this couple walked out of the club
and uh the the woman came over to me and
she was like oh I'm so glad you said
that you know you really changed the way
I think about you know I'm really and
and she was like you could tell she was
really inspired and she was like we're
gonna have children now you know I was
oh right now we'll go for it but but
then I we were talking a little bit more
and how old are you and she went on 43.
I mean
it could it could but probably not
and I I fell that that was a kind of
sign to me that I shouldn't keep quiet
about it
because I don't want people to end up in
that position where that realization
comes that late and there's maybe not a
huge amount you can do about it and I
think that's tragic actually and I think
the whole slew of people from our
generation we're both 40. if you're a
woman RH and you you haven't you know
you're in you're in trouble right so
this is a really serious issue not just
like for the survival of South Korea but
like for people's sense of fulfillment
and well-being and happiness and all of
that and increasingly I meet and hear
from a lot of people who are in that
position so it's a really important
issue but as we talked about the top
down do this this is what all of that
that isn't going to work so other than
you and I thirst trapping people online
what else can can be done culturally
about this if it's a cultural issue
yeah I think you know the kind of the
the policy wonk type stuff I think
should be done not necessarily because
each individual policy does something
but because it signals that this is a
kind of a priority of the state
um and I think it should be because you
know very few things are uh are as
serious and as imminent I think the
problem that we have with the kind of
democratic politics is that people think
in like four or five year Cycles uh and
it's like okay what what's what's
burning now and these things like this
is like generational multi-generational
issues and it's very hard to uh bacon
kind of a long-term view because you
know what's what's the return going to
be on whatever you know politicians uh
yeah priorities for the next five years
so I think that's the challenge but
um given the fact that you know a lot of
people really
um are are having this problem and the
fact that this is like the main theme of
this conference is not just because it's
filled with you know weird like
Westminster wonks because it isn't it's
filled with a lot of people who who
maybe have gone through you know trying
to have children or have have gotten to
some some issues with it you know we're
talking about housing we're talking
about all this stuff and they're trying
to solve these issues and I think this
is symptomatic of a change in the
culture as well I mean this you didn't
hear about this five years ago though it
was already kind of a problem if you in
the South Korea sense it was already
kind of an issue but now it's an issue
as well because I feel many people from
the millennial generation or so are
starting to feel the burn of this as
well like they're seeing
people in their cohort either trying to
have children not managing to have
children or you know having pretty kind
of depressing lives you know trying to
you know keep going to the clubs with
their you know wrinkly whatever and you
know it's not it's just not yeah it's
not a satisfying thing so
um I think it's it might have a chance
to just be be picked up and you know
through a myriad of thirst traps uh from
from influential people such as
yourselves I think it's going to yeah
you know because also as well it leads
to the problem of mass immigration where
we have a labor shortage in this country
and the only way to fill it is to get
people from overseas and that creates
its all but its own problems yeah of
course I mean it's this is Again The
Five-Year cycle it's like yeah for five
for the next five years this is an
extremely good you know you're going to
solve patch the problem but immigrants
get old immigrants stop having kids as
well um you know it's it's it's the same
type of thing you're just getting in
essentially a new dependent class
because you know they're they're not
they usually have you know maybe more
children than the than the typical you
know Westerner for maybe one or two
generations but it the client's already
fairly steep once they get here because
of urbanization because of the
incentives of living in the space
because of you know the fact that um
obviously their children will be
educated they want them to to come here
to be educated the girls will be
educated they have other aspirations for
their lives and then you know even if
they're in a bit more of a traditional
context uh you know the memes of
modernity are are flooding in the pill
you know maybe maybe they didn't have
the pill back in Afghanistan I
definitely have it here
um yeah and uh and what is high status
in the culture is not you know being the
Trad wife or whatever having lots of
kids it is I don't know participating in
all the self-creating cool authenticity
stuff that we discussed before
um so yeah I think that's
but it also leads to problems within a
nation because the lack of cohesiveness
within the nation you know people from
different cultures mean that it's it's
not as homogeneous as it once was that
leads to problems leads to problems of
national identity so of course you know
there's there's a flip side to mass
immigration as well oh of course
no no definitely
um there there are many many issues with
mass immigration
um I mean like I said for fertility I
would say yes it's kind of a bit of a
patch in the short term uh but in terms
of of kind of what it does to to to
National cohesion and this is kind of
like very big terminology that's why
people attack it's like oh what does
this cohesion even mean well you know if
if you go to Bradford you see what
cohesion means you know if you if you go
to places where cohesion's broken down
you know you you can I know it when I
see it type and type things you know a
lot of kind of um modern politics is
about kind of the rule of experts you
know bring bring your own spreadsheets
bring your own graphs and type of stuff
and I feel like a lot of the problems
that you have of mass immigration
is just um you know kind of the sound
the silent disenfranchisement of people
who used to live here you know it's like
this whole like white flight type
discussion people just kind of you know
slowly moving out it's hard sometimes to
quantify or people don't really want to
quantify it because it's not a not a
favorable statistic to to the incentive
structure that the people in politics
want to build
um so it just you know you just wake up
one day and like you know Bradford is
majority I don't know exactly Bangladesh
Pakistani something like that
um and you know people might say oh
just the way the cookie crumbles is fine
whatever you know but it's not just that
you know you obviously have
um The Grooming gang crisis I mean
Scandal you know whatever just like this
pervasive Insanity that happened with
the majority Pakistani grooming gangs um
and also because there's kind of a
silencing on this and you know people
don't really want to rock the boat they
don't want to be anti-immigration and
things like that these things tend to
escalate to a point where you know it's
it's it's really it's really
unsustainable
um and yeah this stuff doesn't make it
into the into the GDP calculation it
just you know overall GDP is growing you
know it doesn't matter what Bradford
looks like it doesn't matter if you know
you know that you know the girls are
tortured and Telford or something like
that GDP line goes up that's what you
know most of the policy wonks care about
so
um yeah that's kind of what's going to
flow into the statistics that's what the
experts are going to care about
um but yeah and I think like that's a
lot of stuff that's kind of low status
and so right-wing politics and things
like that is based on you know things
that are nakedly visible to the eye that
are you know obviously painful for
people experiencing them
um but that somehow don't make it into
the statistics you know it's one of the
things I wanted to ask you about because
you're one of the people that I see
talking about status a lot High status
low status
um and I think Ed West talks about this
quite a bit as well it's uh it's a very
interesting way of looking at why some
ideas are popular and and others not
because I think it's tempting
particularly if you're like us you care
about truth you sort of tempting to
think well if something's right
then other people are gonna but that's
kind of not really the way we think
about these things is it yeah I think
status is a really important variable
that yeah a lot of people Overlook
because
um you know yeah people tend to think
that okay we're the world operates on on
Truth claims okay if something's more
um
science-based is something's more kind
of knowledge based and then something
else that will somehow for some
mechanism went out in the end but in
reality kind of the way
um Power works and the way ideas become
influential is who exactly holds these
ideas you know how do they propagate the
fact that they hold them
um who is influenced by them and you
know it's kind of you know we we hear
that you know the argument from
Authority is a fallacy but it's pretty
much how how arguments work you know and
even even you like for example if you
want to inform yourself about whatever
kind of you know strange topic that you
don't know much about you know you go to
x expert and see okay what is the
consensus in the field maybe you listen
to one or two speakers or something and
then you from Authority and take that
guy's word for for it and now because we
have so many domains pretty much every
domain of life is a domain of expertise
and that's kind of what we believe in
um you know the argument from Authority
is pretty much what we what we all
believe and then status in every field
is how kind of that Authority is
conveyed okay and so you have that in
um pandemic was a good example of this
uh and actually whichever side of the
argument you come down on now and now
this is what I was going to ask you
about because now with I I feel that so
many of the issues that we're talking
about are product of social media uh
because social media gives status to
ideas that aren't true but sound good
and punishes ideas that are true but
don't sound good I think in in a way
that even discussion in the mainstream
media doesn't even reach that level like
the level of derangement on many things
on social media is Amplified by the fact
that it really rewards things that sound
nice and therefore High status versus
things that don't
um do you think that's a big part of it
the the social media entering into the
friend that's one of the reasons that
there's such a separation now as well
yeah I think social media kind of
exacerbates what is already present and
human nature yeah I think if you if
you're in like a little band of people
in your village you had kind of the same
instincts of okay I'm going to trust a
high status guy and I'm going to think
this guy's a loser because he's whatever
since whatever loser signals and I'm not
going to believe his religion I'm gonna
believe this guy's religion
um and that's kind of what you have on
social media and whoever you follow
they're the they're the influencers and
you're gonna kind of side with them even
if they make some crazy statements
because an interesting thing that I've
noticed about even like political social
media is that the clustering of
positions is sometimes not very coherent
like you know you had for example with
covet at the beginning the most
intensely locked down Pro lockdown
pro-masking or people on The Fringe
right because they were kind of early on
this they there's a lot of them in Asia
for some reason and they um they were
really kind of uh you know on the
barricades and learning about this and
telling people where they get their
masks and stuff and then it kind of
flipped when it became a little bit more
mainstream people you know at first it
was all about hugging your friends in
Chinatown and stuff like that in the
mainstream and then it flipped it was
all you know this is the end of the
world we need to we need to lock down
um and it you could see the kind of the
status hierarchies like solidifying in
real time because you know it wasn't
clear exactly what the position was at
first but then it was clear okay you
know my people believed this we believe
you know vaccines Are Holy we need the
masks we need the lockdowns it's all
good if you're against us you're a part
of this other tribe and obviously
there's also an incentive for the other
tribe to say oh really well then yes
exactly yes I am the anti-masking people
I am anti-vaccine people and it just
lead to like definitely more derangement
in terms of like people holding on to
positions really strongly than you'd
have in you know the the village with
the loser guy and the high status chat
telling you what religion to follow so
yeah I think there's definitely a lot of
kind of mechanics built into the
internet that like the slot machines
we're not used to like social
escalations that we're not used to
dealing with in real life it's we're not
built for that that scale of
I don't know exacerbation of ideas and
it's the answer to get off the internet
just sorry is that the only answer
because I don't think we are going to
get off the internet yeah yeah it's a
tough one like to be honest with all
these Technologies like you know we're
gonna get off the pill are we going to
you know get off of the Industrial
Revolution yeah you know this it's the
toothpaste meat tube type situation uh
because we need it I mean you know we
both make our living off
broadcasting on the internet you know I
want to read the comments see what
people are talking about I want to see
who the guests are I'm kind of stuck
stuck in it in a way and I feel like
just personally I'm just now I'm trying
to kind of moderate my use of it you
know trying to be
yeah I don't know try to be very
paternalistic with myself and how I use
it because no one else is going to be
but I can see how you know how how much
of a downward spiral it can be for other
people who you know for some reason or
another maybe don't have you know good
self-control not that I have extremely
good self-control but you know I'm I'm
really you know doing my best to do this
um but yeah it's you know it's another
thing that that is and can be predatory
if it's not put to good use
um and I think this is kind of a dynamic
that you see a lot nowadays in terms of
you know the the space we're in with all
these Technologies and all the stuff
that's really changed in the last 300
years is really good and gives like
insane returns to a very small percent
of people you see this everywhere from
dating Marcus from the economy you know
there are a few people who are very well
placed in terms of being like very high
IQ high conscientiousness low
neuroticism type people who can just
take this stuff and just like plug into
it like robotically and just you know
make the most money you know get the
best partner things like that and then
that works out for them but because it
is such a there's so many wild cards
here for the other people this is
essentially like a predatory the fact
that this is all just like completely
you know very like you know build your
own adventure non-paternalistic we don't
judge type stuff but it is really yeah
it's it's quite aggressive for the for
the people who are just not equipped to
to deal with it so you know we've kind
of built our society around the idea
that you know freedom is perfect it's
it's really good but I think there are
gradations of of how much any individual
person can consent to this stuff both in
the sense that the stuff is getting more
predatory by the year like every year
the stuff you know with a B testing like
everything's more refined
um and I feel like a lot of people who
are at the top you know tend to be very
libertarian about this it's all fine but
I feel like there's um it's coming for
you like you're not you know you might
say you're going to plug into the AI and
become like a superman but you're not a
Superman yet you know you've even with
your high Q type stuff
um it'll get you like some one of these
traps will get you eventually and
um you know it's you know for now it's
okay that it's just kind of like
consuming the plebs and whatever but uh
yeah it's it's coming it's coming to a
true theater near you yeah I could I
couldn't agree with you more and I I
think what people fail to realize was
social media is that it is dementing and
that yeah we like to think that we're
immune I certainly did until you know
you one day you end up losing your head
and just
get getting drawn into an argument and
before you know it you're a seven it was
seven o'clock in the morning you're
looking out and it's the Sun is setting
and you've spent however long you know
saying things that you deeply regret yes
we've all been there yes I mean that's
one of my rules on the Internet is to
not engage in in beefs and yeah one of
my other rules that I don't follow
pretty much is to not read comments but
I do read comments in the end and then
people tell me like oh you know you're
really fat and I'm like well what
but one of the things that Moving on but
still focusing on the internet that I
find really interesting is the Left
Right Paradigm where people used to say
I'm left I'm right well because
everything has become Niche due to the
internet what you see is political
movements becoming fractured and
fragmented and it at first it happened
with the left where I originally was on
the left and then I saw wokism and we
all know what happened with that but now
I'm seeing on the right and the
fractures start to appear on the right
so what do you think of that what's
happening on the right and where do you
place yourself yeah it's it's a tough
one I mean if you ask me that maybe a
year or two ago I'd probably have like a
you know a name for the place where I
place myself but now I'm not so sure
just because I've I'm kind of in the
more kind of dissident right right wing
space and I kind of know the different
factions now and it does feel like it's
the fracturing is more of a product of
what's going on with the medium itself
like with the internet itself and the
incentives that are set by the platform
so obviously you know what what are
these movements they all are they have a
few key influencers some of them and
they kind of set policy for the
movements
um and to grow your specific Circle you
kind of have to cleave off audience from
the other circles and then you enter
into these beefs for whatever point of
Doctrine you know there's beef around
you know should we be a wife guy or is
you know women loving loving women and
having a peaceful home with them gay you
know or something like that
this is this is an important
conversation on the right obviously
there's a split between
um religious and atheist right-wingers
or people who are like maybe more into
like Pagan Vibes and things like that
um that's a big fault line so you know
that that's kind of you know and
obviously the the influencers in these
in these spaces especially because now
there's more attention to these space
because there really is a lot of you
know generative interesting stuff
happening there that's why I'm in the
space
um they're getting a lot of attention
you know there's a bit of money actually
people are getting uh whatever signups
and whatever sub stack money
um and yeah there's more incentive to to
present yourself as you know the the
actual air of the right wing in general
and this is the program and my ten point
program is much more coherent than your
ten point program and yeah people
fighting about over immigration like
there's a the major fault line now is uh
between people who are um kind of
Christian and they're essentially
looking forward to you know a right wing
kind of a Christian core as kind of the
morality of whatever proposed state that
they'd like to live in and people who
say oh no Christianity essentially just
means you know open borders because you
just let in anyone in the world who's
Christian and that obviously has a lot
of you know bad side effects in the
sense that where it's pretty much a
square one and we have the same social
ills that we have now but everyone's
nominally Christian so yeah I mean
that's kind of the the main divide here
and I I there is something to these
arguments obviously they need to be to
be discussed but the fact that they end
up you know in the sense that okay we
need to purge you you know you need to
we need to cleave you off and we need to
whoever is with me has to stay on this
side of the fence and whoever is not
with me needs to leave it's um yeah it's
definitely a it's a it's a interesting
and Lively time to be and and right-wing
Politics on the internet
um but yeah it's still it's still I
think one of the most interesting places
to to hang out
um and you identify as being to quote
your words dissident rights and what
what does that actually mean what do you
believe um
or the horse space I mean what I believe
I mean I've you know I don't think I've
I'd say I have like a you know political
program to implement tomorrow but I'm
definitely I'm more of a kind of a
suspicious of of
um mainstream right politics I mean I
share the same values I mean I think we
should have a society that has kind of a
relatively core normative ideas of of
how to live life you know the the two
family types two parent family type
situation and that uh policy should be
geared towards supporting that and you
know we should be having a kind of a
long-term consideration of what our
societies will look like which brings in
the kind of the birth rates conversation
and all of this stuff I think religion
should have a a kind of a revered
position in society though you know my
personal relationship religion's a
little bit tortured and I know but um
yeah I think you know I'm kind of
right-wing in the sense of yes my values
aligned with pretty much I would say
most right-wing people who would
consider themselves right-wing what
decision right brings to the table is
kind of um a more or
granular critique of power like a lot of
people in the distance wouldn't say that
you know okay we just need to win the
next election because I think the the
main Epiphany that they've had is
post-trump post-brexit is that things
just don't work that way you know it's
not like you win an election and you
have power and your side has power now
you do your your side swings
um we discovered that you know there is
a whole substructure kind of managerial
substructure you call it the blob call
it the cathedral call it whatever you'd
like
um that um essentially has a as a mind
of its own and it is fueled by status
it's fueled by what the elite the actual
Elite who's in power not the figurehead
guy who you voted in or out
um and uh what what they believe and
what what fuels them and what interests
them and for now the major
um kind of ideology behind the elite is
some form of wokeness you know the most
interesting and powerful people in the
world believe some form of wokeness of
either because they are True Believers
but I think most of them are or because
it is useful to them because it has you
know some useful characteristics for uh
for the upper class because they can
essentially have kind of this very
profound moral Vision where they can not
only feel good about themselves for you
know flagellating themselves because you
know whatever white guilt and all this
type of stuff they can hate the people
that they usually hate which is kind of
the middle and lower middle class and
then they can also kind of virtuously
give handouts to their client classes
which are the lower classes you know
people immigrants you know all the the
world Coalition the woke pyramid that
you want to uh obviously they don't
mingle with these people but they are
their client class and they can make
promises to them and they can gang up on
the middle obviously because the middle
is always the contender for the top spot
you know you're not worried about you
know the people in New them you know
you're worried about the people in
Cornwall you know and you don't want
those to come in and get you so yeah
it's uh so Alex that being the case if
winning elections doesn't solve things
what is the dissidence right version of
the solution there are many there are
many solutions that's always kind of
where the where the thing breaks down a
little bit because the solutions are
typically a more a more centralized form
of
organizing Society oh there's a relief
authoritarianism great I mean you know
you call authoritarianism but uh
you know this you know democracy is you
know is something that is quite recent
in in human history I mean we've had
some form of of monarchy pretty much
since time immemorial there's always
kind of
um you know that's kind of the hierarchy
you know you have middle management
upper management at the at the top
there's a CO in any organization that's
functional you know except for the state
where apparently we're all kind of
co-partners and we're all CEOs in our
own right but in reality that's not
really how it how it works I think the
main critique isn't that um you know a
democracy on paper is is bad is that
democracy in reality is essentially a
shadow oligarchy it's like it's not that
um you know it wouldn't be good for it
to be this way where you know we have
these really relevant people who
actually have power in government that
we can all vote for in an informed way
and you know this is this all sounds
great I buy into it but
witnessing the process of politics how
the sausage is made in reality what you
have is essentially a whole cast of
people who you cannot see who are
unaccountable who are distributed within
this whole kind of Hydra of
managerialism and you know like with
covet like who exactly you know has been
held to account for the fact that most
probably this this stuff escaped the lab
most probably a lot of the policies were
were completely misguided like an
extreme amount of you know a lot of
people died because of the policies I
mean you know because of issues with
policies around the hospitals
um so you know
there's absolutely no accountability for
this stuff there won't be a neuro and
back trial for for covid because there
are no figureheads you know you can
shoot him or you can you know it's it's
clear because he was obviously in charge
of his division he had his middle
management he had all the people under
him
um you can you know French Revolution
style kill the king
because you know who he is and he's
responsible for x or y so I think
um that's kind of the idea it's like
okay if you want to have any sort of
functional organization you need to have
a chain of command you need to know who
the guy at the top is because you know
when you when you go out to have your
little French Revolution to to oust him
at least you know who he is and and
that's it and it sounds really a lot of
people who would happily have Matt
Hancock down the road from here I
promise you sorry man no but isn't that
the problem with every type of
government every type of government a
Constantine is obviously from Russia you
know you had the figurehead the leader
but you also had the shadowy bureaucrats
chai Cheska is the same thing my mom's
from Venezuela Maduro I would happily
kill right but he's also got his cronies
none of whom that I know so isn't that
the problem with all government addicts
yeah in a way in a way it is I mean I
think it's it's a problem of scale as
well um and it's a problem of you know
the fact that a lot of the managerial
system that we have now on government it
really is kind of necessary like you
know back in the day you didn't have
like FDA EPA type organizations which
you know people might you know not not
think they're extremely effective but
you kind of need them now because the
complexity of the whole system really is
like incredible
um you know you need to have consumer
protection you need to have all these
types of things so it really is hard to
see who's who's in charge of these
things
um so yeah I think I think there is an
issue with that but I mean you know with
ciao school we didn't shoot the guy and
then things did change I mean slowly he
had like a 99 approval rating yeah yeah
it tells you a lot about democracy yeah
it's not really a democracy oh I just
dropped my mind yeah well it's not a
democracy when you don't like it is it
you still like the result yeah yeah
I think you know I think a lot of people
on dissident right would say that uh you
know our democracy might be closer to
that than you think you know to the to
the figurehead type so so how what's the
solution then as I fiddle my microphone
back in my pocket
of the solution I mean there's like I
said there's there's different proposals
I'm not sure that I've you know buy any
of them in in like wholesale but the
idea would be um you know a lot of
people are interested in kind of more
decentralized ways of organizing Society
like you know like Charter cities and
stuff where it's kind of much easier to
have kind of a CEO figure at the top
where it's you know small you
essentially
um buy into this community and then you
also have exit rights so you don't
necessarily have a voice where you so
you vote for the guy but it's like it's
whatever Constantine's Charter City he's
the boss here
um I kind of like what he's doing with
the place and then I applied to get in
you know Constance says you're nice okay
you can stay here and if you know it
hits the fan you can have exit right how
many wives am I allowed to have on this
because that's really I don't know it's
your Charter City Constantine you know
what you have to decide I am now part of
the dissident right because this sounds
great uh I strictly want this one by the
way I mean but this is kind of the
American model we saw this particularly
during of it you know a lot of our
friends moved around the United States
it's a good model yeah well I I am
envious as hell you you do need a big
country to do it and a federal
assistance or multiple countries or
multiple countries right exactly uh but
that is is actually what happened is
people are sorting themselves based on
their preferences about how they want to
see the relationship between welfare and
government and taxes and freedoms and
opportunity and so on and so you see
those more liberty-minded people moving
to places like Texas like Florida and
there are plenty of people in California
I was just in California a few weeks ago
there are lots of people you know
there's this narrative as like everyone
is leaving your life there are lots of
people who are really happy living in LA
and they're staying because they are
comfortable with the trade-offs that
they have of course uh even they don't
like the machete attacks but as they
told me they have an app now yeah of
course they have an app so machete
swerve yeah something like well right is
that what it's called
you came up with that straight away but
this is literally a conversation I had
with somebody I was like they were
asking me about oh we see all these
knife attacks in London I was like oh
yeah I was just watching a video of some
guy with a machete and they were like oh
yeah we have that here but we have an
app we put it in and then everyone knows
to stay away from that area for a couple
of hours there's there's a way in which
these things kind of self-segregate at
one point you know it's like you know
we're talking about white flight and
stuff like that you know it's you know
you could call it kind of
brazilification where you have the
high-rise next to the favelas and
there's a really really functional wall
between them and then you know people
live relatively peacefully there's some
you know issues between them but yeah
that's kind of that seems to be kind of
the equilibrium that that these you know
these cities which you know we have the
kind of the donut cities model where you
know the inner city is just completely
deserted and then the suburbs are
flourishing and then you have kind of
the commuter towns around and then you
kind of people swear of each other
swerving the machetes so it's
essentially a future in which people
start to
build their communities according to
their Valley systems I
think we most likely I think kind of see
a lot of people doing that already in
practice or aspiring to do it yeah
there's not really you know you kind of
have to coordinate around something I
mean obviously I'd love that something
to be like the the nation state and
stuff like that but it might just be the
case that you know the nation state was
a social technology for a different era
where you know nations were at war with
each other and you kind of have kind of
Nations representing relatively
homogeneous ethnicities not just like
you know economic zones so now I think
it might be that okay people will
arrange themselves after maybe religion
maybe whatever you know their
transhumanist Ai devotees and they want
to I don't know whatever have well some
set of values you know like for example
we are here at naccon neither Francis or
are particularly conservative or
nationalistic really we welcome you well
what but this is my point exactly this
is my point exactly which is that
um there is overlap in terms of values
between different groups of people I
wrote a piece of my sub stack after we
came back from America about the old
school liberals in America and
conservatives trying to work out a way
to work together on things that they
actually agree on
um and that's kind of maybe what you're
talking about and I have to say I I
joked about being part of the distant
right but I genuinely think that
in Britain it's unlikely because we're
too small a country but in America I
totally see that happening and and
everyone I talked to about their
experience of doing that they seem
really happy they seem really happy you
know like this is Rogan was like oh move
to Texas is great and there are people
in Florida who are delighted to be there
like I said there's people in New York
they love being in New York and it's
it's the value system that works for
them
um
I'll be thinking about this yeah I think
it seems selfie segregation yeah a
natural way that that things are kind of
panning out you know there's a lot of
talk about kind of theoretical ideas in
these spaces like you know the integral
estate everything's going to be Catholic
no it's not this is very very hard to
that's definitely a toothpaste that has
left the tube a very long time ago not
putting that back in so yeah you know in
theory a lot of things are possible I
think in reality something like this is
more likely I mean you have this as well
in irania you know in South Africa it's
kind of a relatively famous thing where
you know you have the afrikaners having
trouble with the surrounding issues
politically they essentially you know
made their own City and there's very
strict rules of what you can do it's not
like it's you know it's not walled off
but it's very clearly enforced with
what's allowed in there and whatnot a
lot of people have problems with this
because it's you know it's very it's
it's for the Dutch ethnics of the
country and obviously it's it's very
monochromatic in irania but it's uh yeah
it's one way of solving their problems
so it's a highly functional Society in a
sea of absolute chaos and that's you
know one way it's like a you know a very
uh you know and the anti-favella so I
mean the problem is with that is it's if
it's done on racial lines
um kind of not there moving I mean
they're down with it
so was Apartheid you know what I mean I
mean it's not a part-head in the sense
that you know this is literally just
private property it's like it's like a
reservation it's like gift of you know
Indians and in uh in America would say
okay we just buy this plot of land and
we live there which is essentially what
they're doing now and but it's just
because it's endorsed by the state yeah
but here it's not endorsed by the state
it's just these people know each other
they have private property and they have
so much of it that it's essentially a
town and you know if you're at least a
little bit libertarian you say okay
that's you know pretty much fair enough
I have no they can't come into your
house why should they come into their
compound right I have no problem with
people you know wanting to you know if
shows share ideas and all the rest of it
I'm deeply uncomfortable when it comes
to the racial aspect of it where people
just go right we are ex-group of people
and I understand that obviously but in
that you know I think
in a situation like this where you're
essentially at War this is you know
whatever you think about there's a lot
of violence happening in South Africa oh
great
um the racial aspect for the people
living in irania is a good rule of thumb
you know if it's if it's if your
family's in danger and uh if if that's
kind of the thing it's not that people
of different ethnicities can't come in
around like literally there is but they
have a police force so no like deviation
from you know Law and Order will be
tolerated you literally will be taken
off the premises if you start you know
mucking about yeah so
um you know it's you know there's a
limit to
um to tolerance sometimes I I agree
there's a limit to tolerance when it
comes to things like crime the thing
where it loses me is if it's done on
pure if we were essentially creating a
mini ethnos today I think they're
creating a mini ethnic state in practice
and not necessarily because that's you
know that's that's the ethos of it but
it's like you know this is it is it is
for their community and they happen to
all be Dutch Dutch ethnics or you know
from africaners essentially
um and I think you know they do this for
a reason because not doing this has been
you know quite fatal for a lot of them
so
you know um I'm all for freedom of
Association uh independent of what
Criterion you're basing it on so
what would you accept that in other
nations
yeah why not I mean it's just you know
you buy a plot of land event as well and
populate it with your very best friends
you know and then you have so much money
to buy a really big plot of land
is it
discriminatory that other people can't
come trespass
it's not as if if you're building a
society and you're saying that this
group of people aren't welcome because
they have these type of mutable
characteristics
I would say that there's a real problem
with that and you would outlaw it I mean
what what's the limit there is it uh if
there's a post office then it's bad but
if there's none then it's just like your
backyard you know it's uh I really do
think that people should have the
freedom to to do that obviously you know
this is a question of taste and I think
it's also a question of the conditions
you happen to find yourself in
um and yeah and what you've had to
tolerate up to that point and you know
it's uh yeah it's it's you know it's a
it's a tough place to live in
um and the problem is like the the
Africanus really don't really have
anywhere else to go it's not like they
can go back to Holland it's like the
only place that they can live and you
know I've had people on my show who
um are africaners from South Africa
they're working you know politically to
you know to you know better their
country but the things that they
describe to me you know they a lot of
people like in Cape Town stuff have
um you know bars on their doors and
there's they're you know they're
literally called rape bars for a reason
things like that so they you know
there's a lot of like profound ethnic
conflict which happens along the white
black divide and it's obviously you want
to give people the benefit of the doubt
and a lot of these guys that I've talked
to also have a lot of black friends you
know it's impossible not to do in South
Africa but you know there's
um
a reticence around these things for a
reason and you know I think it's uh it
can be reasonable in some in some ways
uh and Alex we've talked about a whole
variety of subjects uh the the decision
right thing is is an instrument because
I see you kind of Dipping into that as I
watch what you talk about and stuff and
I've always just been curious to hear
your your views on it uh we've got a
little bit of time left what else are
you thinking about
what else am I think of that well um
other than the babies other than the BBC
I think everyone's babied out
um I uh I mean I the subject of my talk
this uh this uh Madcon
um it was a little bit more I guess more
spicy but also it kind of flew under the
radar because people don't really yeah
they shouldn't engage with it as much
um it's uh it's essentially something
that ties into what we were discussing
as well it's um you know it's around the
concept of equality you know we we have
this aspiration towards equality I think
it's it's kind of it's it's very
virtuous you know we want that we have
kind of an instinct for fairness we want
people to
um
to engage with societies to their
fullest and have as much opportunity as
possible but I feel we kind of
constantly hit a snag especially people
who are
um it was kind of more the classical
liberal persuasion and they really do
want you know uh you know we talk a lot
about equality of opportunity versus
equality of outcome we classical
Liberals are for equality of opportunity
while they are for Equity equality of
outcome and I feel like for people who
are more conservative or want maybe to
implement a more conservative vision of
society this is a bit of a trap because
if you say okay I'm for equality of
opportunity and I want everyone to have
equal opportunities it's a very hard
thing to prove politically in terms like
for example if you implement a policy
okay I want
um you know I want to say everyone in
the society has maximum opportunity
we're doing the best we can so that
everyone can you know equalize
opportunities and if after one two three
four generations that doesn't happen and
you have pretty much the same
distribution of people ending up at the
top from different constituencies I'm
saying this is kind of a multi-ethnic
you know men and women are you know
theoretically have the quality of
opportunity
um and you have you you realize you have
the same patterns the same patterns same
patterns
um what you get is an extremely powerful
left because essentially what they're
holding you to is a quality of outcome
because there's no test for equality of
opportunity in the wild but equality of
outcome if you don't get a quality of
outcome after you know the set timer
you're going to be suspected of racism
sexism homophobia all this type of stuff
well it's even worse than that because
on many of these criteria we are
actually there is equality of outcome
across these groups and it's still not
enough yeah yeah of course I mean you
know it's the the ideology of this stuff
kind of takes on a mind of its own yeah
after a while it's you know it's the the
equalization and kind of it it becomes a
bit of um
a religious impulse you know not only
need do we need to equalize these people
we need to uplift them and
um and
write historical Injustice by penalizing
the the oppressor class you know the
people who are who are at the top so
we're kind of in that phase of it as
well at this point I feel like my speech
was more in the sense that we need to be
a little bit more realistic about what's
actually possible as the right we keep
getting into the same we stuck in the
mud in the same equality of outcome
discussion uh equality of opportunity
discussion and everyone's like how we
um you know you also have to kind of
realize that equality of opportunity
even if even if you were to try your
hardest at it it's pretty much
impossible in practice as well because
people come to the table with you know
extremely different backgrounds you know
you know even putting aside genetics I
mean the the cultural aspects the um you
know what did they what nutrition they
have in childhood you know how much can
you
um can you change that and
yeah I think it's it's just a it's just
a losing game and I feel like the right
should be in um in the business of
offering
um like functionality offering
wide-ranging opportunity but in the
sense of okay like color blindness you
know well this is what I've always said
is like I I really reject any sort of
messing around with quotas and any of
that what we should have is no
discrimination based on Prejudice right
you eliminate that and then it's sorry
it's every man for yourself it's a tough
one because you know in law now you have
um essentially the the standard of
disparate impact you have that in the UK
as well under the equality act and in
the US under the Civil Rights Act where
it's pretty tough to prove that you were
prejudiced or not and the way people
proved that there was Prejudice is by
seeing the the outcomes or if you don't
have proportional representation and
expositions people would say okay this
is this is discriminatory you know
because it it really is in practice
pretty tough to say okay why did you
take this camp instead of this one well
you might say oh they had a better
University education but no but they
have more experience here so it's you
know it kind of opens you up to
litigation now and pretty much
everywhere in the west so this is
something that I think as a right needs
to be it needs to be walked back because
it's an impossible standard and it's
like a cudgel it's a rod for own back I
do not recommend and I know it's it kind
of goes it's counter-intuitive because
people really want to have equality it's
instinctive we want fairness but
fairness needs to needs to play out in a
different way and you can see this
especially I mean I'm sorry to say with
crime as well I mean you have rampant
crime in in the US especially and a
little bit here in the UK as well and
there's a lot of issues with um with
policing along racial lines there's a
lot of issues with not you know rocking
the boat with different communities
which we've seen with the with the
grooming and Scandal so you know from a
right-wing perspective what you would
need to have in regards to crime is
um
pretty you know pretty strict and and
clear implementation of Law and Order
independent of how desperate the
outcomes are and I mean that the
outcomes will be desperate because they
they've always been desperate you know
and there's there are all sorts of
factors that flow into here as well you
know cultural factors crack epidemic
whatever fatherlessness which are
factors as well but they're also
extremely hard to remedy and say oh
we're just going to change the culture
it's like we're just gonna say okay you
have to treat your children like Koreans
treat their children and that's gonna
write things that doesn't really happen
it's not how you um how things happen
it's much more organic so we need to
unfortunately treat the symptoms to
protect the citizens from this because a
lot of people forget that the cost of
crime is not just you know the fact that
the poor guy ends up in jail because
that's what we focus on it's you know
the absolutely ruined lives of
communities that that have to live with
these people and a lot of the the
sources of the most crime in the world
are is recidivism like people who are in
out of jail or not deterred by short
jail sentences you know you know I I
think like something like a three
strikes law or something like that is is
genius because it really is a very small
percentage of the population that does
most of the crime and that also
and destabilizes most of the areas where
crime happens because there's a kind of
a like a domino effect in crime as well
it's like if you are in the crime-ridden
area and there's a lot of crime well you
know crime is the way you make your
money you know gangs and things like
that so yeah I think that's um you know
this is this is a fruitful and effective
area of the right I mean you could see
this with giuliani's policies and you
know after the crack epidemic you know
things things went well for a while
because it was pretty strict and
Draconian and you know people didn't
like it because it um
you know it affected certain communities
more than others it's gonna
because that's just how this is how it
is there you go well Alex thank you for
coming back on the show we're going to
ask you some questions from our local
supporters in a second but everyone
should check out your subversive podcast
and uh we'll see you on locals right now
what or who inspired you
foreign
[Music]